un fallo que enfurece a las familias de
las víctimas un tribunal de París
absorbió a la fabricadora de aviones
airbus y a la aerolínea Air France por
su responsabilidad en el accidente del
primero de junio de 2009 que cubría la
ruta Río de Janeiro París catalogado
como uno de los siniestros aéreos más
fatales de los últimos 20 años
nos dijeron que Air France y airbus eran
responsables pero no culpables ahí lo
tienen y es cierto que estábamos
esperando la palabra culpable
durante 13 años las dos compañías
estuvieron acusadas de homicidio
involuntario por la caída del vuelo
af447 en el que murieron las 228
personas que iban a bordo la
investigación se centraba en determinar
si hubo una falta de preparación de los
pilotos atribuible Air France o si hubo
una falla en el dispositivo de medición
de velocidad responsabilidad de airbag
los investigadores concluyeron que el
accidente ocurrió porque una tormenta
ecuatorial congeló las ondas de
velocidad del avión los pilotos creían
que estaban ascendiendo cuando en
realidad perdían altura hasta chocar en
el Atlántico a finales de 2022 las dos
multinacionales pidieron la absolución
al estimar que no quedaba demostrada su
responsabilidad en el caso escuchamos la
palabra responsable nos dijeron que se
cometieron errores No solo uno realmente
no entendemos Cómo pueden las empresas
cometer errores que no dejaban casi
ninguna posibilidad de supervivencia
pero a pesar de esto es tan absueltos
debo admitir que me cuesta entender el
sistema de justicia de mi país no tiene
sentido para mí
si las aerolíneas hubieran sido
declaradas culpables habrían tenido que
pagar una multa de 225.000 euros cada
una que se sumaría a las indemnizaciones
de apagadas y a los altos costos del
proceso que les ha afectado su imagen
pública